I know that this thing went viral forever ago,
but I don't really like to buy the things when they're viral,
cause I'm a little skeptical.
Maybe we're all just buying it because we're all just buying it.
So I know it's prime has passed,
but I'm glad I got it.
This back massager thing.
Look, this. Okay,
it has little handles.
I do love that part.
Who needs a fucking man to massage you when you got this thing?
It's got like, different settings.
It's got heat and.
Exactly what I thought.
I was like, oh,
this thing, it looks like the right shape that I could put it on,
like other body parts.
Like you could put your leg in it,
like your calf muscle.
Oh, my god. And you can even change the direction of how it's turning.
This thing is amazing.
It's linked here for the TikTok shop.
I highly recommend.